This video is brought to you by Epic games.
What's up wisecrack Michael here.
Do you ever wonder what's happening in your subconscious when you're sleeping?
Have you ever struggled to trace the origin of an idea or thought that you've
had,
and have you ever considered purchasing an international airline to help you
effectively pull off a dream heist? Well, on this episode of the good,
the bad and the brilliant we'll get into all of this and more by breaking down
the 2010 film inception and this film, we watch a team of experts,
dream thieves, pull off an elaborate heist that involves implanting an idea.
Three dreams deep into the consciousness of an unsuspecting rich dude.
Things get very weird and evil dream goes to tries to thwart their plans.
And at the end,
we don't know what's real and what's not to help me avoid getting trapped in
limbo. I am joined by.
Jared Michael, you son of a I'm in awe.
I love it. Um, we're going to have some fun Darlene. Okay. Jared.
So inception is a, I think we could say multilayered and pretty complex film.
Yes. I'm excited that you're gonna help me break it down even more,
but let's start by talking about what's good.
So what is something that you think is good about the movie inception?
Well,
you already just said complex and I would say that it's a complicated film and
it's a complex film.
I say complicated because I think that just discerning what happens on a very
basic plot level is pretty challenging.
And one of the most special things about this movie is that it makes people want
to go to that coffee shop and discuss the movie, break it down layer by layer.
But I also think it's a very complex film because it really does invite multiple
interpretations. And I think that's the Mark of a really special movie,
but I think this movie really is for a younger generation than myself,
kind of the matrix of that generation, because it makes you question reality.
It makes you question whether or not you can tell the difference between
dreaming and sleeping like Descartes or something like that.
And it's also a reminder that original and challenging ideas can
still be accepted and celebrated on a wide scale.
And that's something that we unfortunately get so rarely that the matrix was
also proof of this movie actually made way more money than the matrix.
So this was just kind of a big celebratory moment for all fans of
cranial, geeky, scifi and stuff like that. So, yeah,
so this movie has a special place in my heart just because it is just another
necessary movie that had to happen to say, no,
we can invest in original ideas. We can invest in things that seem challenging.
There was an urban legend that nobody even knew what the movie was about when it
was being produced. Like not even the actors knew it was happening.
Another thing that I find pretty impressive about this movie is the opening
scene because a lot of this movie,
just by nature of how complicated it is is needs exposition to even understand
how the rules work. But that opening scene introduces us to so many things,
whether it's the fact that when you get shot,
you wake up in a dream or the idea of multiple dream levels or the idea of how
Cobb's trauma with his wife manifests in endangering missions and stuff
like that. And even like kick, right. I think we get that and we get the kick,
all of that is established through action.
And I think it's so important to do that first,
before we get into the big information dump section,
because that first part is just so exciting.
And so I think it's really clever how he structured that.
No, I think you're right. And in rewatching it for the first time in a while,
I was struck by everything you just said and how bold the first scene is,
like how much they really jump into it.
And the boldness of Nolan to start a movie that's taking place inside of a
dream. And we don't know what's inside of a dream yet and letting that unfold.
Great. You don't know what's going on, but, are you curious?
It's a rip off something you said, and especially the matrix comparison,
something I like about this, and maybe that might sound negative, but I mean,
in a positive way,
it inspired a lot of dorm room philosophy and my dorm room philosophy kind of
similar to what you talked about with coffee shops,
thinking of the sort of movies that inspired deep discussion about what it
really means and the questioning of reality and things that maybe you're going
to talk about this in concert with some books you're reading,
or maybe you're just throwing around ideas while you're stoned with your
buddies.
But I think this movie inspires a lot of those big questions and I think a lot
of the best films have that kind of matrix and inception genre do that
inspire thought, inspire questions and leave a lot of things up in the air.
And I think this movie definitely does that.
Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah.
One of the other things I think that he does so well is create a system of
rules. This movie is all about establishing rules and then for better or worse,
it takes a long time to establish these rules.
But the rules really do work in concert with the way that we
experienced dreams, the idea of nesting time within dreams,
that's something that, you know, we can fall asleep for an hour,
but it feels like we've almost lived an entire lifetime.
That's the first time we ever saw that in a movie. And that was really special.
Yeah. Well, in rewatching it, I was pausing to take notes of the rule. So like,
okay, if you're one level, this is how much time you're two levels.
This is how much time. And even like keeping track of where they were,
what they were doing in the rules of that place. It's kind of demanding.
And on first watch, I think it's easy to not pay attention to that,
but it is interesting that when you rewatch this film,
you can pay more attention,
go deeper and try your best to understand the rules of the unconscious as
outlined by Christopher.
Oh, just the premise of this movie is probably the coolest thing about it.
I mean,
just that a dream thief enters your mind in order to incept you or
extract the most powerful thing in the world and idea. I mean,
even just that log line, if someone were to pitch that to me, I'd be like, okay,
great. But how are you going to actually make that into a movie?
And I think that the ambition of the idea it does show and just how many genres
this movie has to juggle. I mean, it's a drama.
We get the love drama between Maul and cob. It's a heist movie,
it's an action movie and all of them work in concert to create
something that even if you're not aware of what's going on at each second,
it still builds to a moment of catharsis that works whether or not you're able
to say what exactly is happening in the snow level,
because there are a lot of dramatic beats that go by so quickly.
But one of the great things about Nolan is that he doesn't really care
much to hold the audience's hand through pop points,
because he's very aware that there are so many other things in the filmmaker's
toolkit, whether it's sound design or composition or things like that,
that will communicate the stakes more so than dialogue.
I remember when the trailer for the dark Knight rises came out and no one could
understand what Bain said, sorry, it wasn't the trailer. It was, uh,
before mission impossible for there was like the extended intro I showed.
Who I was till I put on the Mars.
And he defended himself against people who said, this is stupid.
We can't understand what Bain said. And he said,
it doesn't really matter if you can actually understand every single word,
because the general tone or the context or the atmosphere that I've built will
give you enough information. And people made fun of him for it.
And he eventually did cave and concede and reward those main lines.
But that's always something that I've admired about Nolan is that he's willing
to challenge the audience to the point where even his editor says that people
don't understand his movies,
meaning that he's going through and putting in beats that are seconds
long, knowing that it will go straight past the audience's head.
But it doesn't matter because they're going to understand that the stakes are
rising. They understand the overarching stakes,
but not necessarily the specific beats. And it still works.
I also think at a more basic level, it's just such a visually stunning thing.
Absolutely. It's so styled, everyone looks so cool in it as well.
So it's a fun world too.
It's a fun world to be in.
And it's just so impressive how they created four different color palettes to
express four different worlds.
And what I understand there was no actual coloring and post-production all of
that was done in camera,
just because Christopher Nolan is a purist and he levels these kinds of
ridiculous challenges at himself just to be the best.
And I think it pays off because more to my point about not needing the
dialogue to necessarily communicate every plot point.
He can just do that visually because a lot of,
a lot of this movie is juxtaposing between different dream levels.
And the fact that you can tell visually that they're distinct from one another,
like one of them is raining.
One of them is colored a little bit more blue than the other one.
One of them has much more of like a warm reddish hue inside that hotel.
And so we're constantly able to understand what's going on.
Something I like about the film is even when it doesn't work, it's still good.
And for that, I mean,
even at times where I wonder if that plot is collapsing onto itself,
if certain threads aren't coming together, the way he wants them to,
that never gets in the way of the movie being so visually impressive and
compelling. The part of the movie that I think gets this really well is the, uh,
the fight scene that takes place in this spinning.
Hallway, the shot of the movie. Yeah.
And the fact that they constructed that. And I think that commitment to not,
I don't want to say cheaping out cause I movies cost so much money to make. Um,
but rather than doing effects in post or CGI or whatever,
building an entire spinning hallway to do that pays off. So wow.
Seen that set and it's very reminiscent to the set that they built for 2001,
a space Odyssey where the woman walks up the circular hallway.
Just a great thing about Nolan films in general. I mean, not to veer too much,
but like it's something that works really well in Dunkirk.
The fact that he made a lot of that stuff actually happen and insisted on having
actual effects, not doing everything in post.
It really pays off in the intensity of the film. But before we continue,
I want to give a shout out to this week, sponsor house party,
a free to download app, LinkedIn, the description,
if you're feeling bored and want to connect with friends,
Houseparty is a fun app that allows you to call them and play games while you
hang out. The app features, heads up chips and guac, quick draw,
and my personal favorite trivia.
They even give you fun facts while you wait for your party to join the call,
add friends via contacts, Facebook, and even Snapchat to get the party started.
Eight friends can be in the same room at once. And the more people,
the more fun the games you can even invite friends who don't have each other's
contacts into the mix.
It's a great way to stay connected during times when friends and family feels so
far away.
So change up the quarantine conversation and download Houseparty today.
Houseparty is free to download and available on iOS,
Android Macko S and Chrome click the link in description to download the app.
Now back to the show. Okay. I'm sure we could.
We could go on and talk about more things we like about this movie,
but we wouldn't be doing our jobs if we didn't also consider what doesn't work
and inception. So give me something.
You think is bad about this movie, you know,
bad is kind of a hard term to level at this movie,
but there are things that I think are a little bit disappointing.
And I think one of it is that some of the biggest action set pieces,
the most impressive ones and most visually stunning ones are only for the sake
of exposition. So for example, the streets of Paris exploding,
when DiCaprio's explaining to Ellen page, how dreams work,
that's really just something that teaches the audience, how dreams work.
But man,
I would love to see that kind of explosion happening during an action sequence
where the tension is high more so with the whole thing with the city folding
in upon itself, that's the coolest, most iconic visual,
except for maybe the Joseph Gordon-Levitt hallway scene, which we talked about,
but at a close second is the city folding in on itself,
which is such a cool thing.
And I would love to see Leonardo DiCaprio being chased by somebody with a folded
over city. But again,
it's just shown almost as pure spectacle because another thing that's a little
bit disappointing about this movie is the rule that he establishes that your
subconscious will come attack you if you change the world too much.
And the only reason for that is because I think it inhibits the creativity of
what can happen when they're actually in the dream. So again,
I would love to see Ariadne just constantly creating throughout that,
like she's playing a video game, like she's playing dreams,
that new game that's out for PlayStation four or whatever.
So much of this movie is a celebration of the creative process and not
being able to see Ari Adonai doing her architecture is kind of a
missed opportunity, I think.
Yeah.
And I think that emphasis on the movie spending too much time on exposition
makes sense of a lot of the flaws.
So one thing that I don't really like about the movie is that, you know,
Ariadne is like really the only female character that isn't just like
in Leonardo, DiCaprio's unconscious in the film.
And her main role in this movie is to ask why almost everything she says in this
movie is like, why does this work like this way? How does this happen this way?
You got draw from stuff, you know, right. Only use details, uh,
a street lamp or a phone booth,
never entire areas because building a dream from your memory is the easiest way
to lose your grasp on what's real. And what is a dream?
Is that what happened to you.
There to sort of represent the audience,
asking what the hell is happening right now?
Because there's so much to establish. Yeah.
And it just sort of a waste of a really interesting character and it's still a
good character Ellen page crushes in that role.
But I would have liked to see more in that particular role right there. Um.
A lot of that could have been achieved if you just made her character a little
bit more active and given the architect role less of a, well,
she already did the work before the actual high starts,
which is how it works now and actually have her building throughout the dream.
By the way that train sequence,
I would have loved to have seen more stuff like that. I mean,
seeing a train with no track,
just plowing through downtown Los Angeles when a training that is such a cool
image.
And I wanted to see more kind of Satoshi con paprika level,
crazy stuff in a dream. You know, I don't know about your dreams, my goals,
my dreams get pretty weird and.
Well, well, we might get to that later.
So I won't let you go too deep into that one,
but something you mentioned before was the way in which Christopher Nolan
establishes so many rules.
Now this is a point where I get how that works for the sake of the film.
I do think there's a missed opportunity in the exploration of the unconscious
and dreams in particular.
So one of the things about dreams and especially if we're thinking about like
the psychoanalytic tradition is they're not linear, they're pretty weird.
The rules of reality don't apply.
So I wonder if there was a more interesting place to go both with this story and
even visually kind of,
as you referenced before to make those dreams pop,
to really push the limits of that.
I get how that would have complicated an already complicated film a lot more,
but that is something that I couldn't help.
But think about when watching this film again.
The thing that we mentioned in the good section,
but I think it could almost equally work as bad as the fact that even the editor
of the film says that people don't know what's going on in his movies.
And I think that for the most part, for most of the dream levels, I was,
I think, beat for beat following what was going on.
But I think everything kind of goes to hell with the snow level.
And I think a lot of that has to do with the fact that Tom Hardy's character
and, uh, the guy who plays cyto, they're all masked up.
So it's really hard to follow who's doing what, uh,
but also just the number of changes in beats that happen in that scene.
There are so many,
and some of them are communicated with just like the smallest bit of dialogue.
So it can be a little bit frustrating, but again,
it mostly works for those other elements that I mentioned before.
Yeah. The other thing I don't like, and this is very minor, I don't like that.
The main not motivation for Leonardo DiCaprio's character cob,
but the reason they get into this heist to begin with is so some super
billionaire guy can stop another company from competing with him.
And there's the line about like, Oh, there'd be an energy monopoly.
It's like my guy, you just bought an airline to do this highest.
I just don't think like that to try to moralize it in some way.
Like this is like, Oh great. We're, we're breaking up the big corporations,
like come on. And I get Cobb's motivation once these kids get back to America,
but also the why can't you just take the kids to France? I won't get into that.
They have this.
Offscreen character of the shrewd mother-in-law that they kind of have that
establishes, like why they can't go to France.
And then too,
like she's presumably married to the Michael Kane character and he's like,
I'll hang out with the guy that everyone thinks killed my daughter,
my wife though, she's out on that. But there's some loose ends.
It is what it is. This movie. Doesn't try to explain all those things.
I'm nitpicking a bit before we move on.
Any other thing that's bad about this movie that you wanted to bring out?
You had already brought up that Ariadne is basically just an expository tool.
Um, and yeah,
I just want to reiterate that I think her character had the potential to be the
most active and cool character,
but she played an unnecessary role that I understand again,
creating this whole complex,
complicated world within two and a half hours,
you're going to have to implement some sort of a tool like that to make sure
that the audience is getting all the information that they need,
not only with how the world works, but also with Cobb's past,
because so much of the romance between Cobb and Maul is just flashbacks.
And we need some sort of motivation for that flashback,
unless you just want Leonardo DiCaprio looking in a mirror and then we just fade
to white and then we see a flashback, which you know, uh,
I don't know.
I think that would feel a little bit strange for a movie made in 2010. Yeah.
But I think the main takeaway from all of this is almost everything we said that
was bad, except some of the minor points are necessary.
Evils of what makes the movie good. Right.
So if you're going to have bad stuff in your film,
have it work to make the film good. So I think we agree on that. Done. Good,
done bad. I know you're excited to get to the brilliant.
We break down the big ideas, but first we gotta do the lightning round. Um,
so I assume you came with crashes.
Okay. With questions, Michael,
if you could incept your girlfriend with any idea, what would it be? Oh,
that's so real.
I would make her like live music more. Um,
I love going to concerts and she doesn't like coming with me. Cause then I'm,
she gets anxious and like crowds.
So I would incept her with that idea that she needed to like be out more live
music and that'd be so much fun. So if you see this, I'm sorry.
I would never really do that. I would never, I would never,
what is the weirdest dream you've had that you remember that can comfortably say
in this context.
Man,
I once had a dream that I was fighting the whole cast of mortal
combat and I was losing and it was a bad dream. That's dark. Yeah.
I'm glad you survived the kick in that one. Must've been very hard. Yeah.
It was bad. I mean, no fatalities, luckily. Nice.
If you had to extract a piece of knowledge from one person living today,
who would it be and what would you extract?
Okay. So in some of the original, um,
hot chicken shops in Nashville Prince's and Bolton's,
they have these spice mixes that they don't tell anyone what they are.
They're very militant about this.
It'd be cool to extract the spice mix to the original style of Nashville.
Chicken is instead of corporate, espionage is small business espionage.
Now I feel really bad. I wouldn't do that. I would,
I would extract a Jeff Bezos. That was the law's money.
That was a great answer.
If you could live an extra lifetime with a loved one in the span of one second
of this lifetime, would you do it? No.
Why not? Well, a w in the sample size of the film,
50% of the people that went down that road killed themselves because of the way
it ravaged their psyche.
So I just think if we're doing risk award reward analysis,
I just think it's worth it.
Well, hold on.
That person killed themselves because they were incepted with the idea to
question their reality and they just kept questioning their reality.
I here's what I still think.
I think that one of the joys of life is its finitude.
And I think that because we know that life's about a certain amount of time,
but if I go do 50 years and then I come back and I got to live a bunch of
longer,
I could technically get up to the point in my life where my lived experience is
like 130 years. I'm gonna be bored at that point.
What do you think is Christopher Nolan's best?
The dark night? Great. That one was super as simple as that.
If no one was hired to direct the next installment of a known franchise,
which one would you want it to be in? Why? Ooh.
This is fun. Um, see, I know that this movie's already been made,
so this is obviously could never happen. I mean, let him do a matrix movie.
Ooh, let him do like a second matrix trilogy.
And I think his aesthetics and storytelling would actually.
Work better. I'm excited. I mean,
I'm excited to see what Lana comes up with the matrix for,
but I might even be more excited if no one does.
I think that would be the level of excitement.
I think if they announced Christopher Nolan was going to do a matrix movie
through the roof. Yeah.
With Lana supervision maybe of course, with supervision or just blessing. Yeah.
Okay. Jared.
Of you were a part of the dream heist team. What skill would you bring?
Whatever Eames does, whatever Tom Hardy's got to do and having other characters,
I guess he's kind of like the actor.
In, I think he's like the forger.
Forges people. Yeah. That would be fun. I was.
Really funny. He killed it. Okay. I like that. And that's a good role.
Yeah. You got another one for me. I do. And this is kind of a trick question.
Ready? Oh, this is a pot possibly going to offend some people,
but who is Nolan's most interesting female character.
This is so messed up. Um, I think Maggie,
Jill and Hall's character and the dark night. Very good. Pretty fleshed out.
I think the reason it's hard to answer this question is because Christopher
Nolan does a bad job of creating interesting roles for women in his films.
It is what it is.
I don't think he tries very hard cause he just knows that that's not as
strength. And I'm fine with that. Some dudes are just dude centric and I'm cool.
That.
I don't know. I would like him to try better. We'll see.
It does not look like anytime soon.
No, there's no good Christopher Nolan's sex scenes.
It's because he's probably just, he's a cranial guy. He's not a sexy guy.
Let him, let them.
I have already has never had sex over the Christopher. Nolan is an adult Virgin.
Who's never had sex lives in a sexless marriage.
And his children are via the extraction from his testicles directly implanted
into his wife to have kids never had sex. Tell everyone, well,
this has been a fun lightning round and thank you for participating. And um,
now that we've done good, bad and lightening round,
it's time to get into the big ideas in this film,
the stuff that makes you think.
So we'll get into the brilliant and you can start us off by telling us what's
something about in steps.
That you think is brilliant. Well,
I mentioned this already a little bit in the good section,
but I really admire how this film inspires so many different interpretations.
And there's one in particular that I've glommed on to that even in interviews,
Christopher Nolan has been approached about.
And that is how inception is about the creative process of making a film.
Have you heard about this? Right? Yeah.
So there's something very brilliant in how there's a scene where cob is
explaining to Arianna how the logic of dreams work. And he said.
Never really remember the beginning of a dream.
Did you always wind up right in the middle of what's going on? I guess. Yeah.
A lot of people have interpreted this as being,
as Nolan pointing to the fact that sometimes a scene will just start and you're
in the middle of a conversation. You don't know how they got there.
Just like they don't know how they got to this place in the dream world.
And so this opens up a whole awesome world of questions about this
movie. So when we cut to things like the establishing shot of moon bossa,
we ask ourselves like, okay, well there was some narrative ellipses there.
So does that mean that we're supposed to question whether this is a dream or
not,
and then it really draws this really interesting comparison to how the logic of
movies works, like the logic of dreams.
So every time we see something like when they're in Mombasa and DiCaprio is
being chased, he's running through an alleyway that narrows to almost a point.
And you're saying to yourself now,
is that just something that a filmmaker is using its film logic to just
heighten the stakes? Or is it an indication that it's a dream?
And then cyto all of a sudden just shows up, well, you know,
what is he doing there? And then we ask ourselves, well,
is that just convenient movie logic? Or is that the logic of dreams?
And this comparison I've always thought was just so brilliant. And as of,
as a film lover,
and one of the greatest things about Christopher Nolan is that he's a film
lover.
It's just a really amazing love letter to
cinema.
And it's interesting that in a great wired article that I recommend everybody
read,
they interview Christopher Nolan and they actually asked him if this is what he
was thinking when he was writing the movie. And he said, no,
but it's clearly there.
And he actually has this great quote that speaks to a lot of what we do.
He says,
one of the things that you do as a writer and as a filmmaker is grasp for
resonance, symbols,
and imagery without necessarily fully understanding it yourself.
There are interpretations to be imposed on the film.
That aren't necessarily what I had in my head.
And it doesn't even have to be necessarily interpretation of what's real or not
is Cobb dreaming at the end or not.
But these meta readings about the creative process that are so unique to this
story about dreams and creation that I just find really special.
Yeah. That's really interesting.
And I read the article you're talking about as well, everyone should. It's good.
And I think Nolan's no one's ability to be like,
this might not be what I intended, but yeah, it's also true is really great. Uh,
and I think it almost acknowledges like the unconsciousness of a filmmaker.
Who's doing stuff. Maybe not even realizing he's doing it,
which kind of leads into the thing. I find the most brilliant in this film.
And not that this is something it's intentionally doing throughout,
but something that's really interesting to think about is the theme and the
function of repression. Um, so of course,
Maul and a lot of ways is a repressed symptom of trauma
in Cobb's unconscious. Something that's happened that was horrible,
that he's pushed down so far, but the repression wants to get out.
Now this is something that's in a lot of ways can be pulled right from Sigmund
Freud. So I have a quote here. This was when, when Freud first introduced the,
uh, category of repression and he said, and this is him talking about patients.
He was seeing.
So as there was some force that prevented them from becoming conscious and
compel them to remain unconscious, push the pathogenetic experiences.
In question out of consciousness,
I gave the name of repression to this hypothetical process.
So repression for Freud is when something happens that our mind sort of
puts away for us, tries to keep down.
But the repressed memory keeps trying to like break into our conscious mind, um,
and sort of disrupts patterns.
That's why a lot of times people might experience trauma as a child or some
horrific event and they push it down,
push it down and it might be 30 years later that that's popping up and haunting
them. And I think that through them all character,
the film explores that idea in a really interesting way.
And even if we read the film or that part as sort of a metaphor,
it's reminding us that past trauma can be ghost these things that haunt us,
these things that we can't get rid of.
And even if they don't actually exist as specters,
they're already deeply inside our unconscious mind,
which is wild to think about.
Cause all of us have things like that floating around our subconscious mind that
we're not aware of that might pop up at any point.
And I think the movie gets at the implications of that and a really interest.
We actually have an actual physical embodiment of his trauma who
is messing with his life and, you know,
having your trauma be the antagonist of the film or at least of select scenes is
something really cool.
Oh definitely. And I think kind of connected to that.
There's some fun ideas to pick apart in terms of how memory functions,
because I at least wonder when I watched this film,
how much of what the cob Leonardo DiCaprio's character is remembering about
Maul actually happened?
How much of that is shaped by his own remembering of his memories
and something we know sort of a psychological and neurological level.
We do this weird thing where we have a thing that happened to us.
We remember that, but by reremembering it, we can modify it. We can change it.
So eventually we get further on and as adults,
we have to acknowledge that some of our childhood memories might've drifted
pretty far away from what actually happened.
So you wonder that in the film as well,
how much of the re inscription of these memories is shaping then
who Maul is? Yeah, absolutely.
And I think that's what he discovers at the end when he decides not to stay with
mall and limbo first and foremost is because he realized that she's just a shade
of the full woman that he wants to.
Yeah. And there's something that's so real and melancholic about that.
Cause in our own lives like people, whether it's friends,
we just don't see any more people who have passed the memory of the person is
never quite the person. It's always a shell of something real.
So I really liked that level of exploring how memory functions,
what else did you find? Brilliant.
I'm going to go back to the Metta reading about film because as a film lover,
this is the one that resonates with me the most,
but on top of the fact that the logic of dreams run parallel for the logic of
cinema,
something really interesting is that the whole idea of incepting somebody with
an idea of planting a seed of thought in someone's head as something that cinema
does to people that view it.
I find to be really awesome because that's something that's actually happened to
me. I mean,
I've made blogs on this channel before about how the matrix changed my life and
virtually the witch house keys went into multiple layers of my subconscious
and planted that idea to question things.
And that came to define me just like it came to define mall just how it came to
define Fisher at the end of the movie.
And so being able to think about the creative process in this kind of
high stakes spy,
like scenario is just so satisfying.
Yeah. And that's another thing I was thinking about as well,
was this notion of the Genesis of ideas,
where do ideas come from and the complicated way in which most ideas that we
consider,
self-generated still relate back to something else are still built on top of
other ideas are the seeds of other things.
And often those things do come from the media. We consume the films,
we're watching the books, we're reading, who we're talking to.
So in that begs a lot of interesting questions and just provides a lot of food
for thought. Really. So now that we have talked about it at multiple levels,
we have to take all of that intricate discussion and reduce everything down to a
three option rating system. We have to decide is inception good,
bad or brilliant? Jared, what is.
I think it is very good.
I'm not willing to quite give it to brilliant because once again,
I think that the film does buckle under the weight of its own ambition.
But that is to say that it swings for the fences and basically hits most of the
marks. I will say that some of the REI nice stuff is a little bit of a bummer.
I think that, um,
it's a bummer that it takes an hour to get into the action of the actual heist,
no matter how you cut it. Um,
and I think that although in a lot of heist movies,
the exposition is supposed to be pretty exciting.
This is something that was trying to balance a drama and a heist movie.
So a lot of that first hour isn't as exciting as it is so much an information
dump. So that's the only thing that makes me say that the film isn't, you know,
brilliant or like a masterpiece and it's not my favorite Nolan movie,
but I will say that it's very good.
Oh, that was great. Um, I'm going to defer a little bit.
I'm going to say it's like average. Good. Okay. Just straight up. Good.
And for me it is the Ariadne stuff mixed with the fact that I still think parts
of the movie don't make sense and I want it to make more sense than it does.
Maybe that's just me. Uh,
it's something I do want to rewatch I'll I will watch it again,
but for me it's just good, but not bad. Similar.
You're just on a little higher end of good than I am, but either way,
I think we both agree that if anyone hasn't seen this movie it's worth the watch
that we watch it. Yeah. Um,
so a new thing we're doing is recommending some reading or viewing if someone
was into this movie and just some of the ideas from it,
we'll tell them something to look into. So I can start with you.
Is there anything you think someone that enjoyed the movie and enjoyed this
discussion could read or watch if they wanted to dive in.
Little bit deeper? Yeah.
So a couple of years ago we did a wisecrack edition on inception and talked
about this, reading about it, being about movies and dreams.
And there's actually a film theorist slash film editor. He, uh,
his name is Walter Merchy edited apocalypse. Now he edited,
I believe the godfather,
he's a very famous editor and he wrote this book called in the blink of an eye
and he has a whole chapter on how the logic of film and the logic of dreams
parallel each other that works really well with how this movie functions.
So in the blink of an eye by Walter merge, I recommend.
That's fantastic. Uh, mine is a book, not, not that exciting, I guess,
but if anyone really liked the exploration of memory and the unconscious and
especially the theme of oppression, um, I recommend that you check out Sigmund,
Freud's five lectures on psychoanalysis.
And this is one of the series of lectures where Freud gets into the idea of
repression. So I think if you liked the Mol character,
if you liked what was going on inside of Leonardo DiCaprio or Cobb's mind,
it could be a book that you enjoy. Cool. Yeah. Um,
well this has been really fun. Absolutely. Thank you for doing this. Thank you.
Now, normally I would ask where we could find someone, people know where to go.
If they want more Jared in their.
Lives, you know, you're already there. This has been.
The good, the bad and the brilliant on inception.
Thank you so much for watching. And please let us know in the comments,
if there's other properties you would love to see us cover in the future.
We will see you next time, please guys.
[inaudible].